the more members of Congress can avoid
making difficult decisions the easier it
is for them to achieve perpetual
re-election since toppling longtime
incumbent bob bennett in the 2010
primary and then writing the Tea Party
wave to become the junior senator from
Utah Mike Lee has been one of the most
careful and Liberty friendly legal minds
in public office as a member of the
Senate Judiciary Committee Lee will
participate in the upcoming confirmation
hearings of Supreme Court nominee Brett
Kavanaugh a fact he was almost in the
hot seat himself the senator was one of
seven finalists considered by President
Trump to replace retiring Justice
Anthony Kennedy I sat down with Mike Lee
to discuss that selection process as
well as concerns over Cavanaugh's Fourth
Amendment views and the latest on the
senators long-standing goal of getting a
sentence reform bill onto trumps desk
thank you so you got snubbed again
there's like two times you've been
snowed by the president for not coming
on the Supreme Court are you licking
your wounds how do you feel about that
well look I know honored to have even
been considered honored to have been on
the list along with my brother my
brothers on the Utah Supreme Court he
was also on the list who's better
between you and your brother oh my
brother hands-down okay but you know if
it's gonna be anyone other than him I'd
like to be considered I know you don't
want to talk about specific
conversations that yeah but the
president's right presume if you want to
spill the beans that's fine but can you
give any kind of sense of his
preparation his interest his just kind
of his approach towards the issue
because his naming of judges has been a
pretty interesting part of his
presidency am I understand the
president's been very involved in this
process from day one and he was very
involved in the process of interviewing
candidates and I commend him for that I
also commend him for having put together
a list of people he put together a list
of people while he was still a candidate
and said these are the kinds of people
all consider for the Supreme Court I
think that's helpful
so tell us a little bit about Brett
Kavanaugh your initial ideas what the
things that you want to hear from him
what's your assessment of him from what
you know so far what I want to hear from
him is that he's a textualist
originalist he's someone who will defend
the Constitution that he's someone who
will start each case with the assumption
that there is a right answer under the
law and he's got to find it even though
it's difficult even though some people
might disagree about what the right
answer is a textualist originalist is
someone who will interpret the law based
on what it says rather than on the basis
of what the jurist might wish it said or
what the administrative regulatory state
interprets it as being out there in the
wild precisely precisely you know this
may sound really ordinary very mundane
to say that you want someone who will
just read the law based on what it says
it's actually kind of novel and I mean
in recent history just in the last few
decades we've had members of the Supreme
Court including people who have been
appointed by both political parties who
take more of an approach that says I
want to find what the right answer is
what answer feels right to me and then
that let the law back in to the result
that's kind of a problem but you also
have I mean the Supreme Court is not
immune to politics right and not immune
to not wanting to be too far ahead on
certain issues or he as he wrote I
believe in a dissent on an early
Obamacare case you know we should have a
sense of deference about jumping into
hot-button political fray so that also
comes into it right your your sense of
both on precedence and how much you want
the Supreme Court to butt in on things
that the legislature or the politics
writ large are wrestling with that in my
view the court shouldn't even be focused
on that the court should be focused on
finding what the right answer is finding
what the text says finding what the
statute or the constitutional provision
in question have to say and then
applying that to the case at hand there
are people who I think share a lot of
your overall approach to life in
Congress you might dispute that but you
don't get to who are worried about
Cavanaugh in the Fourth Amendment
particularly third party doctrine on the
cases like the carpenter case that just
came up is that a worry of yours is that
something that you're going to be
focusing on when you look at him the
Fourth Amendment is a big deal to me I
believe in the Fourth Amendment I think
we need a strong Fourth Amendment their
Fourth Amendment is one of the reasons
why we don't fly the Union Jack in this
country one of the reasons why we don't
sing god save the queen
it's one of the reasons for the American
Revolution we've got to stand behind it
and
that includes staying on top of
technology so that the government
doesn't find creative ways of
circumventing the privacy rights
protected by the Fourth Amendment it's
one of the reasons why I was so
concerned from almost the moment I got
into the Senate seven and a half years
ago about the government's practice of
acquiring bulk telephone metadata bulk
telephone metadata collection is kind of
a fancy term for gathering all the
information on basically every telephone
in the United States who you called who
called you when you talk how long you
talked it's a gross invasion of privacy
and this was done without any warrant
without any showing that you or any
other owner of any other phone line had
done anything wrong or had any
connection to a national security
investigation this was wrong it's one of
the reasons I authored the USA Freedom
Act which in 2015 was signed into law
and ended bulk metadata collection now
the opinion you refer to the claimant
opinion is one that was authored by
judge Cavanaugh in that case
interestingly enough that case had
become moot as I recall by the time the
case came before Judge Cavanaugh and so
it was mooted in fact by the USA Freedom
Act so I I'm gonna ask some questions of
judge Cavanaugh I want to find out more
about why he wrote separately on that
point if he answers in the worst
possible way from your point of view
could that be a deal-breaker for you
well look I think this is someone who's
going to be confirmed and I think this
is someone for whom every Republican in
the Senate is going to vote barring
something unforeseen barring something
that I don't anticipate right now I do
think he'll be confirmed but I do have
questions and that's why we have a
process you talked about the president's
approach towards the judiciary and
nomination your colleague and Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell often times
describes the Senate as a personnel kind
of Department and the personnel that
they're trying to to hire or move
through our judges how would you assess
how the Trump administration has done in
filling judges given you were very very
keen interest in the judiciary in the
Supreme Court and other elements the
Judiciary
how would you rate how that process has
gone as a member of the Judiciary
Committee in the Senate I've had a
front-row seat to this and overall I'd
give the Trump administration very very
high marks on this for the most part
these judges have been top-quality
top-notch I was very impressed for
example with Judge Gorsuch now justice
Corr such I hope that judge Kavanagh
will sort of fit into that same category
along with Justice Alito for whom I
clerked along with Justice Thomas along
with Justice Scalia the lower court
appointees have also been very very good
so I am pleased with this administration
what it's done to repopulate the federal
judiciary as vacancies have occurred has
that been a positive surprise I recall
us talking at the Republican convention
or would you had a little red-faced at
times about the proceedings that are
going on in the floor and we're not I
don't think could be accurately
described as a big fan of Donald Trump
at that moment are you surprised by the
quality given what you thought at that
time I don't know if I would say
surprised I I had some uncertainties
uncertainties that I expressed in 2016
as you and a number of other people
witnessed they were uncertainties based
on the fact that this was someone who
was a newcomer we didn't know a whole
lot about him didn't have a political
track record but I would say I've been
very pleased those uncertainties
uncertainties with regard to what he
would do with the federal judiciary
these are things that have made me very
happy I've been very pleased with this
administration in that regard I'm gonna
go out on a limb and presume that you're
not as happy about his trade policy
listen yes yes Roach's this week you all
passed a non-binding Senate resolution
criticizing the the president's approach
on on on tariffs I saw a lot of people
say hey this is a great first step I saw
a lot of people saying non-binding
what's wrong with you guys can you bind
something first just generally speaking
it can assess the administration's
approach so far on trade and the tariffs
and a trade war and and your sense of
that and then maybe we'll get into the
Senate's role and Congress's role and
what you see it as doing or not doing
to kind of combat it or or oversee it I
respectfully but very strongly disagree
with the president's decision to invoke
section 232 to impose massive tariffs on
steel and aluminum first of all I don't
think there is any national
security-related predicate need
established that would even invoke this
secondly I think this puts far more
American jobs in jeopardy then it could
possibly say we've got far more American
jobs that involve making things with
steel and aluminum which are themselves
fungible commodities traded in
international markets far more people
are employed in America making or
selling things that involve steel as or
aluminum as inputs then we do people who
are making steel and aluminum more
moreover with steel for example we can
satisfy all of our national security
needs with just three percent of
domestic steel output just domestic
steel output that that makes it almost
impossible in my mind to establish the
predicate need to invoke section 232 in
the first place look I believe that
there are no winners in a trade war only
losers and I say this is the grandson of
Treasury man a tea man one of the few
law enforcement officers that existed
back in the 1930s and 40s where the tea
men my grandfather helped enforce the
smoot-hawley trade Oh tariff act and
Heba moaned the fact that that had been
his job for years he late in life he
used to experience guilt over it I mean
he was just was his job he was just
doing his job but he used to warn me
that that's one of the things that you
just don't do it's like never fight a
land war in Asia and and don't start a
trade war because they tend to result in
or at least exacerbate global
depressions so I want to keep us out of
trade Wars I think it's a mistake to
start going down this road and I hope
the president will reconsider these are
conversations I've had with the
president both before and since he's
made the decision to invoke section 232
what is Congress doing about this right
now is a non-binding resolution
amount to a hill of beans it's not
nothing but it's not nearly sufficient
as you point out I mean it's it a little
bit like the unarmed English Bobby who
being unarmed upon seeing the commission
of a crime might say stop or I'll yell
stop again this time more harshly what
we need is something binding what we
need is to look to the example of 1980
in 1980 President Carter with a
Democratic Congress in place slaps some
232 tariffs on petroleum imports
Congress a Democratic Congress in both
the House and the Senate said no and
pass legislation to undo that action
President Carter vetoed that action both
houses of Congress then overrode that
veto that's the kind of thinking we need
to be involved in that's exactly what we
need to do bob corker gave a speech
about a month ago I believe that was on
the question of tariffs and he put it in
the context of we don't pass anything
here we don't pass amendments we don't
do any what the hell are we doing if we
actually voted on this it would pass if
we had an actual sense of the Senate
more than a non-binding resolution it
would probably pass and yet it doesn't
get offered what is going on with that
it's a problem this is supposed to be
the world's greatest deliberative
legislative body I'm not even sure what
that means anymore but what it's
supposed to mean is that it's a place
with theoretically unlimited debate it's
a place where anyone can offer up an
amendment anyone can offer up
legislation and have it voted on and not
just gimmicky legislation not just
something that expresses the sense of
the Senate in some abstract way but
actual legislation that's what we need
to do and we especially need to do that
here in the area of trade
it just feels like Congress has been in
a long pretty steady descent in terms of
abdicating its responsibility on any
number of things just pass a budget okay
we can we pass a normal budget with
appropriation bills and things like that
you came into the Senate as a reformer
as a young voice you heard tea party guy
back when there was a tea party and you
know you you toppled the establishment
bringing some energy and some kick into
the place partly from a sense of we need
to have more rich oversight or the
executive branch what's going on why is
there is it just our the incentive
is so strong to not do anything and just
have a single up-and-down vote on a on a
you know a cromnibus bill at the end of
the year what explains the way it
doesn't work it's the drive for
perpetual reelection that's at the
center these six years realize yes yes
exactly but the more members of Congress
can avoid making difficult decisions the
easier it is for members of Congress
whether an they're in the house or the
Senate Republican or Democrat the easier
it is for them to achieve perpetual
re-election and so that's why you've
seen this odd confluence of events
you've seen the centralization of power
power being taken from the people move
to Washington but then within Washington
there's a second step where the power is
transferred from the people selected
lawmakers in the House and Senate or to
unelected unaccountable bureaucrats in
the executive branch who are not
accountable to anyone they're not
accountable to the voters through
election they're not really even most of
the time accountable to anyone who is in
turn accountable to the people through
election this is bad for everyone else
but it's good for us small handful of
politicians who find that this process
makes it easier for them to get
reelected and it's bad for the American
people it is by the way very good for a
small handful of experts in Washington
DC will become wealthy off of the
complexity that surrounds Washington DC
you raised a related point by the way
and referring to the way we spend money
by the way we pass appropriations bills
more often than not we don't have a
regular process in which individual
members are allowed to craft legislation
or change the way that our spending
bills are put together we're instead
given a pile of papers sometimes a
couple thousand pages long a few hours
before the expiration of a spending
deadline that's wrong when there's no
opportunity for debate for discussion
for amendment for individual members to
improve it you've effectively
disenfranchised almost 300 million
Americans unless you're one of those
lucky four members named perhaps Ryan
Pelosi McConnell or Schumer then you're
being shut out of the process that's not
right so it's malpractice it's it's
stunning that it happens even though we
can sort of understand the
you are trying to do something with
criminal justice reform which is an
issue that the administration has
expressed perhaps surprising to some
interest at least in some of the prison
reform aspects to that you seem to be
optimistic about some work that you're
doing to match up with a House bill can
you talk us through what's what's in
front of you sure in the last Congress
we proposed something called the
sentencing reform and Corrections Act
passed through the Judiciary Committee
with a bipartisan supermajority vote of
15 to 5 oh this year's version of it
passed out of this Congress's Senate
Judiciary Committee with a vote of 16 to
5 it contains two basic provisions two
basic titles one title dealing with
sentencing reform making some necessary
adjustments to minimum mandatory
sentence laws that sometimes result in
excessive prison sentences for low-level
nonviolent drug offenders in particular
the other title deals with prison reform
preparing people to be released into the
general population helping to make sure
that they're ready to go back out that
they've got the skills the coping
mechanisms and some of the basic
educational inputs necessary to make
sure that they stay away from crime the
House of Representatives has passed the
prison reform portion of that I believe
that can pass the Senate but it can pass
the Senate most likely only if we add a
few sentencing reform provisions to it I
think if we do that we can get most or
all the Republicans and most of the
Democrats to join with us we could get
this passed this year and what's your
sense of the house accepting some of the
sentencing reform guideline I think it's
very high because these are common-sense
revisions that we're making this is not
going to result in opening the
floodgates and letting out a whole host
of dangerous felons onto the streets
these are relatively modest adjustments
so that we can get away from this
Byzantine labyrinth of laws that
sometimes results in some people going
to prison for 55 years for selling three
dime bags of marijuana
over a 72-hour period just because they
had a gun on their person at the time
the President or the administration
people around him have indicated at
least less when I looked at it which is
a longer girl
when you did obviously they're
interested in the prison reform the
sentence reform not so much Jeff
Sessions your former colleague I don't
think it's a big fan of that and a lot
of other criminal justice reforms that I
might like to see what is your sense of
being able to talk the administration
into agreeing to take on some of that
sentencing reform that you would also
like to say first of all I think it
would be a mistake to suggest that
everyone close to the president is
opposed to any idea related to
sentencing reform secondly I think
there's an understanding that prison
reform is necessary and if the price of
doing that involves some modest
sentencing reform so be it let's get it
done that's why I expect victory
sometime between now and a few months
from now that's that's very positive
news and indeed you think the president
is enjoying the applause that he
receives when he uses as a commutation
and and pardoning power there absolutely
i I think he enjoys doing that and I
think he's used that power pretty well
from what I can discern I I think he's
identified some instances in which
people have been mistreated by a large
overpowering federal government one that
has sometimes overextended itself
particularly in the area of criminal law
enforcement last two subject before I
let you go you're interested in passing
a kind of thing having to do the
antiquities act not allowing a president
to willy-nilly use the antiquities act
to you to federalize more national park
eyes more land instead of me describing
it why don't you and tell us what you're
up with of that sure the federal
government owns close to 30 percent of
all the land mass in the United States
it's not evenly distributed at all most
of its in the western United States in
every state east of Colorado the federal
government owns less than 15% of the
land
you've been many if not most States it's
a percentage that can be reckoned in the
single digits in every state west of
Colorado the federal government owns a
lot more than 15% of the land in the
case of my state Utah the federal
government owns two-thirds of the land
that limits our ability to control our
own access to that land what we can use
it for federal land itself can be
accessed with some local in
put as long as it's within some
categories but under the antiquities act
passed some 110 hundred and twelve years
ago the president has the unilateral
power to designate an area as a National
Monument once it's made a monument that
federal land is put into a higher level
of restriction it's much more difficult
to access much more difficult for local
populations to determine the rules
surrounding access to that land Utah has
fallen victim to this and in fact we've
been the victim of millions of acres of
monument designations by presidents who
have done so made these designations
contrary to the will of local
populations and so it's one of the
reasons why I'm proposing that Utah be
given a special protection a protection
analogous to what Wyoming already has an
Alaska already has and Utah's case my
bill would say that if a president wants
to designate any more of our land as a
National Monument it can't take effect
until you first have approval from
Congress and you also have approval from
our state legislature I don't think
that's too much to ask
especially when America's poor and
middle class particularly poor middle
class people in Utah are most deeply
affected by this land we shouldn't be
subjected to any more of this without
our consent the counter-argument to that
you'll hear from environmentalists is
that you are preventing the president
from protecting some of the most
beautiful land in the country which Utah
it undoubtedly is and therefore are you
just going to strip-mine it for whatever
nefarious reasons that you're doing
what's your response I could not
disagree with that statement more
strongly look no one wants to protect
that land more than those who live
closest to it suggesting that we want to
do this so that we can drill under
delicate arch or double arch or some
other national landmark some other
beautiful place is absurd and it's
contrary to the facts on the ground the
fact is that no one cares more about
that land and the people living closest
to it but they understandably
justifiably want to have some input into
how they access that land rather than
having those decisions made thousands of
miles away
by a government bureaucrat accountable
to no one very good well thank you very
much Senator Mike Lee for future Supreme
Court justice Mike Lee for talking to us
for reason I am that well
[Music]